>> DID YOU DISCUSS SO-CALLED
SOCIAL MEDIA BIAS AND YOU
BELIEVE THERE IS A BIAS?
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, I DON'T
REMEMBER EVERYTHING THAT WAS ON
THE QUESTION.
>> THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
I'LL MOVE ON.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, SURE.
WE ACTUALLY DON'T APPOINT
INDEPENDENT FACT-CHECKERS.
THEY GO THROUGH AN INDEPENDENT
ORGANIZATION CALLED THE
INDEPENDENT FACT-CHECKING
NETWORK.
THAT HAS A RIGOROUS STANDARD FOR
WHO THEY ALLOW TO SERVICE
FACT-CHECKER.
>> Greg: WHAT A CONTRAST.
REMEMBER, WHILE ZUCKERBERG
CREATED A COMPANY THAT EMPLOYS
THOUSANDS, AOC PREVENTED AMAZON
FROM EMPLOYING THOUSANDS IN THE
CITY SHE REPRESENTS.
ZUCKERBERG'S BIG QUESTION IS HOW
DO I CONNECT PEOPLE VERSUS HOW
DO I LOOK ON TV.
>> YOU HAVE RUINED THE LIVES OF
MANY PEOPLE, DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST THEM.
YOU KNOW WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS ARE ON
FACEBOOK IN COMPARISON TO THE
MAJORITY, FOLKS?
DO KNOW WHAT THE PERCENTAGES ARE
DO KNOW WHAT THE PERCENTAGES AR
ARE?
>> PEOPLE USING FACEBOOK.
>> YEAH.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE PERCENTAGES
ARE FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS
QUESTION WORKS BECAUSE I DON'T,
BECAUSE WE DON'T COLLECT THAT.
>> IT CAME OUT IN A REPORT.
MAYBE YOU JUST DON'T READ A LOT
OF THINGS THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
CIVIL RIGHTS OR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
>> Greg: CELL, WHERE ARE ALL
THE FACTS CHECKERS IN THIS?
I GUESS BRYANT'S BELTER IS BUSY
FACT-CHECKING TRUMP'S TWEET.
>> ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
LGBT COMMUNITY ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS ASSOCIATION,
MR. ZUCKERBERG?
>> Mark: I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER.
>> WHO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY ARE
PART OF THE COMMUNITY?
>> WOW.
ZUCKERBERG DOESN'T KNOW HOW MANY
GAY PEOPLE WORK ON AN IDEA.
THAT IS A HUGE PROBLEM.
AFTER THE SHOW, WE ARE GOING TO
GET THE WHOLE STAFF TOGETHER AND
ASKED THEM IF THEY LIKE MEN,
WOMEN, OR BOTH.
I THINK THAT'S TOTALLY LEGAL.
NO ONE IN THAT ROOM WILL EVER DO
IT MORE TO HELP PEOPLE THEN THE
GEEKY GUY THEY SLAMMED WITH
QUESTIONS.
THEY FIND A SACRIFICIAL PINATA
AND BEAT THE STUFFING OUT OF IT
ON THEIR HOME TURF.
THEY MADE HIM INTO A STRAW MAN
AND SET FIRE TO HIM.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT ZUCKERBERG'S
POLITICS ARE, BUT AFTER THAT
HEARING, I KNOW WHAT THEY SHOULD
BE.
HE SHOULD DESPISE BIG GOVERNMENT
AND ITS ENABLERS.
HE SHOULD NEVER TAKE THESE
CLOWNS SERIOUSLY AGAIN.
MAYBE HE SHOULD STOP BEING SO
POLITE.
THEY WANT TO DESTROY YOU, MARK.
NEXT TIME D.C. COMES CALLING,
LET IT GO TO VOICE MAIL.
SO, DANA, HOW DO YOU GRADE HIS
PERFORMANCE?
HANDLE AND AT CALMLY.
ARROGANCE IS PRETENDING YOU KNOW
SOMETHING YOU KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
SOMETHING YOU KNOW NOTHING ABOU
ABOUT.
>> Greg: IT WENT ON FOR HOURS
AND HOURS.
HE NEVER LOST HIS COOL.
I THINK THAT HE IS SO
EXCEEDINGLY CAUTIOUS WITH HIS
WORDS, BECAUSE ONE, HE DOESN'T
WANT TO OFFEND PEOPLE.
IT ALSO RECOGNIZES THAT HE HAS
2 BILLION CUSTOMERS.
THERE ARE 2 BILLION PEOPLE ON
FACEBOOK.
THOSE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS, PEOPLE RUNNING
BUSINESSES, PEOPLE DOING NEWS,
ALL DIFFERENT THINGS.
ANYTHING THAT HE SAYS CAN MOVE A
MARKET IN THE SECOND.
HE TALKED ABOUT LOSING A HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE DAY WHEN
THEY MOVED TO THE NEWS STAFF.
IT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
WASHINGTON, THERE ARE SEVERAL
FACTORS COMING TOGETHER.
ONE OF THEM IS THE ANTITRUST
FACTOR.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT IS
THEY ARE SAYING THAT IT IS A
MONOPOLY AND SHOULD BE BROKEN
UP.
DO THINK WASHINGTON CAN HANDLE
THINGS BETTER THAN A PRIVATE
COMPANY?
>> Greg: OF NOT AFTER SEEING
THAT.